I don't want to go don't want to go
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
yesterday we received some really crazy
news that Spider Man Tom Hollands
spider-man will no longer be in the MCU
if you are unaware of this news
deadline.com reported that sony is
pulling spider-man out of the MCU
because Sony and Disney / Marvel could
not come to an agreement when they were
renegotiating the contract of spider-man
in the MCU as reported Marvel only got
5% of whatever the spider-man films did
which really is not a lot considering
how much Marvel was involved in making
this films and considering how much
Marvel did to help spider-man by having
him in the MCU Kevin Feige and Disney
renegotiated for a 50/50 split in which
Sony declined and apparently Sony came
back with a different number and Disney
walked away and today Sony released an
official statement about Disney no
longer being at the head of production
for the spider-man films moving forward
the full statement released by Sony
reads much of today's news about
spider-man has mischaracterized recent
discussions about Kevin feige's
involvement in the franchise we are
disappointed but respect Disney's
decision not to have him continue as a
lead producer of our next live-action
spider-man film we hope this might
change in the future but understand that
the many new responsibilities that
Disney has given him including all their
newly added Marvel properties do not
allow time for him to work on IP they do
not own Kevin is terrific and we are
grateful for his help and guidance and
appreciate the path he has helped put us
on which we will continue so there you
have it
yesterday it was still kind of up in the
air whether or not this was going to be
the case or not moving forward with
spider-man in the MCU but today this
official statement from Sony has
solidified that moving forward Disney is
no longer going to be involved with
spider-man now an official statement has
not been released by Disney yet but
according to Sony is that Disney doesn't
really own enough of spider-man to
continue moving forward unless they got
more ownership Disney only owns 5% of
spider-man and they wanted to own 50% in
which Sony declined but Disney is really
who made spider-man having him in the
MCU is what has made him so successful
as of recent times and the fact that
spider-man was in Avengers in game is
definitely the reason that spider-man
far from home made over a bill
million dollars in the box office and
now the fact is Disney now owns a lot of
new characters after the Disney Fox deal
they now have the rights to all of the
mutants the Fantastic Four Galactus just
so many new characters that they need to
focus on characters that they own 100%
of now so the truth and the fact of the
matter here is Disney just doesn't own
enough of spider-man to focus on him now
again Disney was a massive part of why
spider-man was so successful which is
why they went to Sony requesting 50% and
since Sony declined Disney simply had to
step away and focus on the upcoming
characters that they will own 100% of so
it's a sad day that spider-man really
won't be a part of the MCU anymore but
fortunately for us we have a lot of new
characters a lot of new stories coming
into the MCU that we do have to look
forward to so again let all of your
frustration out in the comments down
below tell me how you feel about this
but also tell me what you look forward
to in the future which characters are
you excited to see finally show up in
the MCU and if you'd like a chance to
win an Xbox one or a ps4 be sure to
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your favorite
superhero or villain so you can enter my
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU don't
forget to follow me on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof